all right uh this is not a saturday
night live skit
this is not a joke
they are now blaming doors for the
shooting in uvalde texas this is truly
beyond parody
uh we're gonna look at a video here of
ted cruz uh ted cruz is not the only one
talking about this you see here a little
screenshot
from uh texas lieutenant governor dan
patrick sorry i'm having trouble getting
it on the screen here it is
um too many entrances and exits on
campuses okay so let's look here is ted
cruz when he was uh in uvalde yesterday
came across this new idea let's not talk
about guns let's talk about doors do you
want to talk about how we could have
prevented the horror that played out
across the street
look the killer this is a principled and
defiant ted cruz bravely coming out
against doors entered here the same way
the killer entered in santa fe
through a back door an unlocked back
door
i sat down at round tables with the
families from santa fe we talked about
what we need to do to harden schools
including he's furious at doors guys
he's furious at doors
not having unlocked back doors including
not having unlocked doors to classroom
having one door that goes in and out of
the school having armed police officers
at that one door
okay
then he went on fox news he this started
to get some traction so then he went on
fox news and did the exact same routine
about doors school's safer and one of
the things that everyone agreed is don't
have all of these unlocked back doors
have one door into and out of the school
and have that one door armed police
officers at that door if that had
happened if those federal grants had
gone to this school when that psychopath
arrived the armed police officers could
have taken him out remember the armed
police officers were there and they did
confront the suspect and then he went in
for 40 to 60 minutes to rampage in the
classroom think about the absurdity of
these people there's too many doors it's
not too many guns there's just too many
doors now let's talk about doors okay
at the high school i went to
now during school hours all of the doors
are locked going in you still have the
push bar so you can get out but the only
door that's unlocked going in is the one
that leads directly into the front
office where people have to check in
fine i mean okay do that that's fine but
remember an armed officer did confront
the shooter outside of the school
and then the shooter went in
and then we're learning that he was in
there 40 to 60 minutes after the
confrontation what the hell is going on
here what how how is doors the the issue
uh secondly children never go outside
for recess
uh when you when the the other concern
from security experts about the one door
thing is
if everybody knows the one door that's
being used
then the shooter can just hang around
right at that door there are fire code
issues as well and you know when when
ted cruz says
we got a psychopath here and the doors
is what we need to do well why wouldn't
the psychopath target the kids backed up
in the line to get in the one door that
will let them through so
locking doors having a police officer at
the school bulletproof windows these are
reactions but they're not solutions okay
and by the way imagine that you do this
at schools do you do it at the grocery
store because the buffalo shooting was
at the grocery store well what if it's
the parking lot to the grocery store
well i guess you put in fencing around
the parking lot and go through tsa style
security to even get into the parking
lot for the for the super guys churches
now okay you've got to solve the issue
of people trying to do the shootings
the doors are not going to be the
solution and ted cruz was actually
confronted by a sky news journalist of
all people we're going to look at that a
little bit later after we speak to
jonathan height quick break back after
this
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video